I've gotten my questions from children
after they've watched the trail oh
really
yes so Kenji 9 years old want to know
why would students be so mean to their
teacher you know what that is they're
mean I think some kids are put on the
curves to just give teachers a tough
time you know nothing that you do is
gonna be easy and you know sometimes you
got to earn it
hopefully they realize not to push
someone too hard or for help and stuff
or they become a super villain and try
to take over the world and eliminate
laughter all right can you just share
your full name because my son laughed
out loud at that my characters full name
is now if I said pee-pee diary and steen
poopy pants
it's choir though eu7 wants to know why
is the principal filming Zoey you're
going to learn that when people become
adults and not everything goes their way
they become angry and maybe someone hurt
them as emotionally at somewhere at some
point in their lives and they turn into
principal crêpes probably not which
wanted here but that's harsh realities
of the world if you were to be Captain
Underpants
what would your costume look like I
think the outfit is exactly right the
only thing I would do is maybe add stars
around the waistband mine would be a
thong and the Cape would ride just on
the back of it ha ha ha lower waist yeah
mine would be a sort of spandex one be
Wednesday including a hood I need to be
layered as foot child so I'm going to
answer this the best way that pass
between qpg I would be naked
[Music]
amazing
[Music]